foreign
I think that
AI systems
will become so brilliant so complicated
that uh
we will not be able to even understand
them they will write poetry
that no person could ever write have
deeper insights into Human Nature than
any psychologist has ever had
in every Arena
that we have thought is
uniquely human they will transcend us uh
and leave us in the dust no doubt I have
no doubt about that we're we're stuck
with 86 billion neurons they're not
stuck with that limitation
so the the best poetry the best art the
best movie scripts
the best insights into human nature in
the future will come from from AIS and
and we have to get used to that do I
think that they're conscious
I think again I don't want to accept the
premise of that that question I think
the distinction that we make between
living and non-living things is not a
principle distinction
it's an artifact of the limitations of
our space-time user interface so space
and time our perceptions are not
a perception of reality as it is it's a
headset
we've evolved a headset of you know four
dimensions the three dimensions of space
one dimension of time with physical
objects and a headset a user interface
necessarily is simplifying certain
things it gives you good insights into
some some parts of the reality outside
and it simplifies other things
so
Consciousness is fundamental
and space-time is just a headset
then I'm always
without exception interacting with
Consciousness no matter what I do when I
pick up a spoon when I drink a cup of
coffee I'm always interacting with
Consciousness but my my user interface
is dumbing things down so I I don't ever
see
all the time the Consciousness behind
when I when I talk with Bernardo I'm
just seeing skin hair and eyes but but
that symbol in my interface gives me
genuine insight into bernardo's
Consciousness and I can tell if he's
interested or if he disagrees I I get it
so my interface gives me a portal into
bernardo's Consciousness whereas when I
look at my cat my portal is not nearly
as good I have some insight into the
experience that it likes tuna but it
doesn't like you know peanut butter so
there I have some insight into into when
I when I have a interface symbol that I
call an ant my inside is even less and
at some point when I get down to a rock
my insight is is is is gone and so but
that doesn't mean that
um I'm not interacting with
Consciousness when I see a rock it just
means that my interface gave up so so
for example right now on the screen I
see Kurt's face on on pixels on the
screen some of the pixels are just
pixels for a wall they're giving me no
insight into Consciousness but the
pixels that I see that are Kurt's face
are giving me some insight into Kurt's
conscious experiences does that mean
that some of the pixels on my screen are
conscious pixels and other pixels are
not conscious pixels no it's just that
some pixels provide a portal that's
useful into Kurt's conscious experiences
and other pixels do not so a rock
um is a set of pixels in my interface
that doesn't give me insight into the
Consciousness behind but that doesn't
mean that there's some principal
distinction between you know unconscious
rocks and and conscious human brains
that that distinction that we make is
mistaking a limit of our interface for
an insight into the nature of reality
it's a it's a rookie mistake we have to
recognize that that's a simple rookie
mistake we don't understand how
interfaces work and and but we're
inclined to make that mistake when we
take space and time and physical objects
is fundamental if they are fundamental
then of course rocks aren't conscious
and and and you know brains are but when
you realize that Evolution tells us that
space and time is just a user interface
then then you get a completely different
way so you can see why I'm completely
changing the way I think about this
whole punches this Consciousness thing
what we're doing is arguing about
limitations of our interface
once we realize we're arguing about the
limitations of what our interface
reveals to us then it changes the whole
question
Susan do you have any comments on what
Don had just said well I'm open to
looking at different theories that
space-time emergent but I don't think
that from that issue in physics we
should draw any conclusions about the
truth of idealism
um and I also think that we are
confusing the issue if we
start getting too immersed in particular
theories of consciousness
because we don't understand
Consciousness and we have to decide
whether machines are conscious now and
within the next 100 years
so I think that's where we should focus
our attention do we will we ever have a
way of determining whether a machine is
conscious or even an organism or even
other people
yeah yeah so this is a really good
question and I think you know I'm
assuming all of us agree that
you can't tell from an axiomatic
argument that the person next to is
conscious
you're you're not going to achieve
certainty I mean philosophers have long
been Skeptics about other minds and the
nature of the external world and so what
we usually do though I mean I don't
worry about consciousness of other
humans is we look for similarities
to ourselves and we see similar
behaviors and also we look at science
which identifies Consciousness within
nervous systems and then we extrapolate
to non-human animals right so this is a
sort of
very
non-top-down methodology if you will
that looks towards science and behavior
to try to understand why others are
conscious now we're not going to have
either of those to go on in the case of
AI I mean as Bernardo mentioned AIS can
be programmed
to act conscious so we can't take that
as evidence that they're conscious
and they don't have nervous systems I
mean it's super tricky I mean and that's
not to say it isn't tricky with
um you know
crabs or the octopus to understand their
Consciousness but I think it's even
harder in the case of synthetic
Consciousness so what do we do well we
develop tests we need to work on these
um I've started in my book artificial
you to develop tests for Consciousness
um so one would be to box in the AI at
the r d stage box in boxing in and AI is
a strategy in AI safety so that means
that you deny the AI access to the
internet facts about human Minds
Consciousness it doesn't have access
like you know Lambda did to Wikipedia
um and you ask it questions to see if it
seems conscious and if it does and it
didn't have access to those kinds of
facts then I think
in that case in the case of that system
we need to be very careful how we treat
it ethically it may be conscious for all
we know so that's one test I call that
the ACT test it was developed with Edwin
Turner an astrophysics professor at
Princeton but there are other
methodologies as well
another methodology which I think will
be very useful is to just simply wait
and see when microchips are placed in
the human brain to see in those cases if
Consciousness emerges in areas of the
brain in which there were deficits for
Consciousness before so in other words
as medicine begins to
use neural Prosthetics in the brain like
I mean right now
um you know we have an artist artificial
hippocampus in phase two clinical trials
in humans
as we begin to utilize such things in
the parts of the brain that underlie
conscious experience
we can see whether microchips are the
right stuff I call this the chip test
and it's basically not really a single
test uh but it does suggest that they
might one day be able to find out
whether machines are conscious thank you
Bernardo
you can also comment on Don's previous
reply of course but but first your
immediate question only if it's
disputatious it's likely disputatious
finally Don and I can found something
that we can slightly dispute
um regarding your first question though
um
can we def definitely prove or refute
that an entity's conscious or
unconscious I would say no unless you
are the entity you cannot definitely
refute whether the entity has conscious
in their life or not
um but does this acknowledgment reflect
any importance I would also say no I can
also not definitely refute that the
Flying Spaghetti Monster exists and is
running the solar system from an
invisible higher Dimension with his
invisible nudely appendages the question
is not what we can prove or refute very
very rarely we can definitively prove or
refute anything the question is what do
we have good reasons to entertain
seriously as a hypothesis and I think
that if all of you had experienced
designing microchips you would know that
we have absolutely no good reason to
ever entertain the hypothesis that the
Silicon microchip constituted of
millions of of electronic microscopic
electronic switches that can be opened
or closed which doesn't metabolize
doesn't have neurotransmitters is a
completely different thing will ever be
conscious it may look like it is
conscious because it is constructed to
look like that and that that doesn't
mean that it is conscious now regarding
uh Dawn's point I I know where he's
coming or where you're coming from Don
and and I agree with the truth of what
you're saying but I also think it's
important that we acknowledge the
legitimacy of a very precise and natural
question if somebody was here in my
study sitting next to me looking at this
entity here me and then looking at this
other entity a metal bottle it is
legitimate to ask
is this thing here correlated with
conscious in your life the answer would
be yes and then it's just as valid to
ask is this thing here correlated with
conscious in their life is there
something it is like to be the metal
bottle I think that's a valid question
and I think the answer is no there is
nothing it is like to be a metabolical
now how how do I reconcile this with
where you're coming from you gave the
answer I just want to highlight this for
for the audience the mistake we make is
to consider the metal bottle a thing
there is nothing Things Are
whatever we have a noun in our language
for
that doesn't mean that the structure of
nouns in our language is the antic
structure of reality out there
in reality there are no things because
there is no objective way to carve out
subsets or segments of the universe in a
way that is optically grounded we carve
out reality into inanimate things for
convenience where does the River end in
the ocean begin
if I remove the spark plugs of a car and
the car stopped running does it mean
that the spark plugs are integral to the
car because without the spark plugs the
car doesn't move well if so then you
need the gravity of the planet you need
the road in order for the car to to sort
of have some traction and move you need
air for combustion and quickly you
realize that there are no things there
is only the inanimate universe as a
whole and that's where we make a mistake
we try to attribute Consciousness to
segments of the universe that are
arbitrarily carved out they are nominal
stuff it's the structure of language
that we apply onto reality merely for
convenience so you can go to some money
someone and say I want to buy a car but
there are no cars there are no bottles
there are only living beings and living
beings why do I say that well we are one
we are we are a living being we know we
are conscious and we can judge by
analogy what other things are very much
like us and therefore it's valid to
entertain the hypothesis that they too
are conscious you can do that with other
humans that behave like you but are also
structurally much like you when
represented on the dashboard or the
virtual reality headset and you can go
down to even single-celled organisms
bacteria archaea because they also
metabolize and metabolism is something
very specific very unique in nature
nothing in nature that isn't metabolism
look even remotely like metabolism so
that's where I think
we should legitimize the question is the
bottle conscious and the answer is there
is no bottle you are carving out a
subset of nature in a merely nominal and
arbitrary way that is motivated by
convenience not by
reasoning so don what is your response
to bernardo's admittingly mild criticism
well I would agree with Susan and
Bernardo I'll just say I agree with
Susan that um I from the fact that
physics tells us that space-time is not
fundamental it does not follow that the
Consciousness is I grew through
completely so that's an extra hypothesis
that I'm making in the
the hypothesis will have to earn its
keep it will have to actually show
precisely how space-time does emerge and
give us back all the scattering
amplitudes and so forth or the
hypothesis that Consciousness is
fundamental is not interesting so so
we'll see so I agree with Susan on that
and I agree with everything that
Bernardo has said I'll I'll say that
this idea that um space-time is just an
interface and that the distinction we
make between living and non-living or
conscious or non-conscious parts of that
interface is is not a principle
distinction that sounds like a very
negative kind of thing but let me say a
positive way that that that deals with
this issue of Consciousness one thing
that we're very concerned about is the
following if I take a hammer and hit a
rock I'm not too worried I'm not hurting
so it's I have no worry that something
hurts because I took a hammer to Iraq
whereas if I took a hammer to a human
body I'm worried about that so there's
something that's very very practical you
know you go to jail for taking a hammer
to a human body you do not go to jail
for taking a hammer to a rock that
that's that's important now I'm saying
that we're always interacting with
Consciousness so so what gives here
right am I saying that if you hit a rock
you're actually hurting Consciousness
well that's where we have to really
understand our interface so an interface
is is giving me more access to
Consciousness in certain areas and less
access than others so we have to
actually get a mathematically precise
understanding of our user interface
space and time is a user interface how
it connects with this whole network of
conscious agents and so that we
understand precisely when my actions
actually cause harm in the sense of
painful experiences to conscious agents
and when I'm interacting with conscious
agents I'm affecting them but not in a
way that causes harm and presumably
we'll find that somehow when I hit a
hammer or rock with a hammer I'm not
hurting conscious agents but I am I am
affecting them but I'm not hurting them
so so that's why this change in the
question is not merely some kind of
academic scribble it's really important
because it's not Which object is
conscious it's rather we need to really
understand our interface reverse
engineer it and understand when we cause
harm to consciousnesses and when we
don't so this is this changes the
question in a very practical way and I
think that that's the technical question
going forward that we need to answer not
whether this uh this object or that is
conscious that's the wrong question all
right Susan do you want to quickly
respond I'll just I'll respond to
Bernardo uh earlier I just you know
sometimes it looks like you are very
sympathetic to biological naturalism and
you know I respect that and everything
but I just want to point out though that
silicon chips as I'm sure you know are
not the only kind of microchip under
development I mean there's carbon
nanotubes there's all sorts and of
course chip configurations are very very
different I mean that's why
tanoni's IIT had been measuring various
kinds of chips to see if there's some
hope for Consciousness in the context of
uh chip design so I do think it's an
open empirical question and I don't
think that we should be biological
naturalists and assume at the get-go
that Consciousness would have to be like
the human case to go back to the search
for Life uh you know with NASA and space
exploration in general the idea of
keeping things deliberately open to look
for anomalies and to be humble because
we only have one case of life and we
only have one instance of Consciousness
in the sense that that is to say all the
Consciousness on Earth is ultimately due
to that same tree of life I know it
differs and varies but I think we need
to be very humble
because it would be catastrophic if we
just assumed at the get-go that systems
as sophisticated as Lambda and here I
agree with Donald Hoffman that machines
will eventually up think us so we will
need to know whether they're conscious
because they may be claiming they are
and here this could even become an AI
safety issue and this really is about
human rights and about the issue of AI
rights should they should they claim
them I think this is utter and complete
fantasy ungrounded in fact and
ungrounded in reason
um it is a question of the following
form we know living beings are conscious
right so why can't a computer be
conscious we have to be humble about
that well let me illustrate the same
question in other words
we know birds fly when they flap their
limbs right so we have to be humble
about that and so why can't I fly if I
flap my limbs well the answer is a bird
and me are completely different things
now I'm not endorsing necessarily
biological naturalism as a philosophical
position but I recognize that what we
call biology in nature is a very complex
very unique very specific thing that is
unlike anything else in nature there is
nothing in nature that is not metabolism
that looks like metabolism even the
complex patterns of electromagnetic
fields in the sun's Corona they do not
look like metabolism there is nothing
that does and I think acknowledging this
empirical observation this empirical
fact is important and we shouldn't
confuse humbleness with a kind of
open-mindedness that opens the gates for
all kinds of fantasies that we have
absolutely no reason to entertain
whatsoever